I feel cagey you ever get like that
feeling cagey and I feel like that a lot
of times um one thing about you know
being sober and not doing drugs and
alcohol is that I get just AM kg man
you know I feel this I feel this little
fire in the back of my neck and I don't
know what it is it's just uh it's like
the devil just lit a match a long time
ago before maybe even before I was born
the devil just little match and just set
it at the inside the base of my brain at
the very very bottom like say if your
brain had like a landscape okay and out
there somewhere at the beginning of the
landscape or in the middle of the
landscape there was a wishing well and
you'd look down in that wishing well and
it's just dark in there and at the very
bottom of that wishing well that's where
the devil put a little just a little
flame and that little flame is just in
me and it's always it's in me and when I
start you know just you know turn it
into that dark night and when I start
dark arting and start being wild buying
liquor cocaine any of that then that's
when I can feel that thing getting you
know heating up heating up inside of me
and it's uh and it just you know and if
I don't do if I don't do drugs and
alcohol that flame is still there and it
still wants to latch on to other things
so it'll still find ways to to ignite
and sometimes those ways are you know
putting 19 coffees in a creamer
sometimes those ways are you know I
remember one time I was at the CVS and
some kids some little kid was being an
[ __ ] and he was wearing striped
shirts he had on striped shirts and
striped pants and right out of that is
that's the most [ __ ] [ __ ] thing
you can do is wear double stripes and
not be an inmate or be a you know a
Hamburglar or you know or not be a man
of constant sorrow and wear double
stripes
and they have one of those little
inflatable basketballs or something that
that you know is for sale and in one of
those little bins or kits and I just I
took that thing out of that little bin
that inflatable ball and just hummed it
at this kid and it and it hit him strong
where that shoulder meets the neck that
soft little shelf you know it's like
just that soft little shelf it just
seems like a lot like a it's that soft
place like just like a lion lick tear
right there while you were being formed
like you were being formed out of clay
and then they were trying to make the
perfect shape for that around you where
your neck meets your shoulder and a big
lion comes and just licks that clay and
that's where they that's where that ball
hit him real hard right in that lion
lick and I don't know if I taught him a
lesson but I I know I taught him
something that boy and I don't know who
he was and that was actually I was at an
a MP and they don't have a MP anymore a
MP was a it was a chain grocery that
they used to have and they had them by
me and and we go over there me and one
of my buddies and this was a young urban
gentleman who was a good friend of mine
him named Evan and we'd go over there
and buy plums and peaches when I was
when I was young but but I'm her one
time acting out that way just letting
that flame that was inside of me you
know it's that flame it says oh go do
that do that that's bad do that do that
do something you know that thing inside
you that makes you want to growl that
makes you want to just you know sharpen
you just sharpen your nails and just uh
and just touch and just you know touch
somebody real hard and aggressively and
that's what that is and so I think
sometimes that's just been you know I
don't know when I get to feeling anxious
I feel like that that thing inside of me
you know they'll the little coffin
inside of me that where the devil sleeps
is starting to is starting to open up a
little and you can see the devil's eyes
kind of just come up in that space
between the lid of the coffin and the
rest of the coffin you can see his eyes
come up and look out into the world
and see what trouble he can call us and
I think I'm just feeding I'm just
feeling that inside of myself right good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one watch
this one